[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان جزءا من المشكل يتعلق بشركه
الاتصالات داخل كل دوله فلقوه الصراع
الحاد بينها وجد عمالقه التكنولوجيا منفذا
للدخول بينها جوجل وميتاج على الصراع بين
شركات الاتصالات عبر لعبه شراء احدى
الشركات المحليه بهدف النفاذيه لدولتها
[موسيقى]
عندما تنظرين في اجمالي ثقي اي شركه
تكنولوجيا لانشاء خط ترين انه لا يمثل
شيئا من اجمالي ارباحها او اي موازنه
لاطلاق مركز معلومات مركز واحد للمعلومات
يتكلف مليارات دولارات ولذلك فان امتلاك
خط ينقل البيانات لن يتطلب الا جزءا لا
يرى من كلفه المشروع كله لذلك فالاهم لهم
هو السيطره وكلما كانت هناك فرصه لهم
لمزيد احكام القبضه على الخطوط عريضه
النطاق فانهم لن يتوانوا عن انفاق المزيد
من الاموال
[موسيقى]